If you want to understand the bind
the world faces
adapting to climate change, there
may be no better example
than that of the simple
air conditioner.
As the world warms and heatwaves
become more frequent,
and more dangerous,
people turn up the AC.
It's very effective
at cooling buildings
and the people inside them.
But air conditioners are also
power-hungry appliances,
with a small unit in a single room
using more electricity
than four fridges.
There are currently around
1.6 billion air conditioners
in the world, and that number
is expected to triple by 2050,
where 10 new units
will be installed every second
for the next three decades.
At that point, emissions from
powering all that air conditioning
could be as high as 2 billion tonnes
of CO2 a year,
about the same as India
produces now.
This is the ever-accelerating
feedback loop of air conditioning.
Higher temperatures lead
to more AC.
More AC drives
ever higher temperatures,
and while this cycle continues,
people will suffer from
the ill effects of extreme heat.
It isn't only about the immediate
danger of death or illness
during a heatwave either.
Higher temperatures can make
air quality worse
and chronic conditions flare up.
Some studies suggest our thinking
and decision-making is more sluggish
when it's hotter.
Extreme heat can leave people
poorer, too,
as working hours shrink,
and infrastructure, like roads
and power, become unreliable.
One way to address the problem
is to simply build
a better air conditioner.
There are UN-backed initiatives
to improve the efficiency of AC,
so it uses less power
and produces fewer pollutants.
But rather than betting
on new or better tech,
it's also possible to change our
approach to cooling and comfort.
Humanity lived
without air conditioning
for much of its history.
Some of the most charming aspects
of ancient cities,
from Mediterranean courtyards
to narrow city streets,
are actually ingeniously engineered
cooling measures
that either block out
direct sunlight
or use cool stones and plants to
keep the nearby air pleasant
throughout baking afternoons.
The picturesque white villages
of southern Spain have partly
been painted that way because light
colours absorb less heat.
This often went alongside
ways of living that were adapted
to the hot weather.
Taking a siesta meant avoiding work
during the hottest periods
of the day.
Those who traditionally lived
in the desert
wore looser, lighter clothing,
like robes.
Placing a wet towel on the head
or neck is common in India.
Simply ensuring you know of a cool
place to move to
during intense heat, like a basement
or shaded room, can also help.
Our predecessors also developed some
clever cooling technologies.
Stepwells, an ancient technique
that builds small pools of water
into a structure,
often deep underground,
to cool adjacent areas have long
been common in India,
while across the Middle East,
striking towers called
wind-catchers
that direct cool air towards
buildings
have been used for centuries.
More recently, people have relied
on electric fans
to circulate cool air,
which use very little electricity.
Including efficient ceiling fans
in buildings
would go a long way to reducing the
quantity of air conditioning used.
Many of these approaches are called
passive cooling measures
because they don't consume energy
but, in a sense,
air conditioning created a different
kind of passivity.
It allowed people to design
frighteningly inefficient buildings
and cities full of sealed all-glass
skyscrapers and concrete surfaces,
and simply cool them down with AC.
Reversing this mistake
for a warming world
requires an active approach -
designing buildings, cities
and reconfiguring our daily lives
to ensure
we can deal with overheating
before it happens,
and treat air conditioning as
a last resort.
Fortunately, greener, more carefully
built spaces for living
should have other benefits -
from the savings that come
with efficient homes to the health
and wellbeing effects of plentiful
green space and safer outdoor
temperatures in towns and cities.
Like the climate crisis itself,
cooling is a global challenge.
An Oxford University study showed
that if average global temperatures
missed the 1.5 degree target set
by the Paris Agreement
and hit 2 degrees,
nations already facing heatwaves,
like those in Central Africa,
will see the most extreme
temperatures.
But northern countries could see
the biggest jump
in the number of uncomfortably
hot days - days when people
will need additional cooling.
In Switzerland and the UK,
for instance,
that number will go up by 30%,
the biggest increase globally.
The researchers warned that
these countries
are dangerously unprepared,
with their homes and cities
built with a very different
climate in mind.
In the UK, homes are built
"like greenhouses",
one of the lead researchers said.
Air conditioning is incredibly
convenient,
but it would be a disaster
for the climate if it continues
to be the worldwide remedy
for rising temperatures.
The goal must be
to turn air conditioning
into a technology of last resort,
using the clever green solutions
of the past, and adapting the way
we live and work in a hotter world.